peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
lorsque nous marchons dans les rues de
la ville et que nous croisons les autres
tous les autres ce que l'on ne connaît
pas il nous arrive parfois de nous
demander qui sont ils riche pauvre
heureux malheureux gay ou solitaire les
gens passent comme le courant d'une
rivière inconnu et nous nous restons sur
la berge sans en savoir davantage
ce soir est un soir d'automne dans les
rues de marseille et les passants c'est
cool
parmi eux un vieillard personne ne le
regarde attentivement ce n'est qu'un
vieillard un vieillard est rarement le
centre du monde
celui là pourtant devrait attirer
l'attention
quelque chose ne va pas dans sa démarche
elle est trop raide trop guindé trop
appliqué comme si chaque pas compter
comme s'il lui fallait suivre une ligne
bien droite sans aucun écart il marche
sans arrêt suivant un chemin qui ne va
nulle part
soudain le vieillard s'arrête droit au
milieu du trottoir à sa gauche une femme
passe à sa droite un enfant et un chien
cabriole il ne bouge pas il est arrêté
tout simplement immobile il regarde
devant lui comme s'il voulait connaître
le reste du chemin comme si les chercher
le but l'horizon qu'il n'atteindra pas
et puis il s'effondre
la réaction des passants et curieuse
personne n'ose s'approcher
chacun regarde de loin ce vieillard
effondré avec étonnement les gens sont
presque bloquée comme s'il était
inconvenant de s'effondrer dans la rue
sans avis préalable
enfin une femme s'approche s'agenouille
et regardent peut heureusement ce vieux
corps recroquevillé elle dit d'un air
surpris
il n'est pas mort et puis c'est
l'attroupement les discussions vous avez
vu mais comment est-ce arrivé qui est ce
qu'est ce qu'il a mais reculer vous
laissez-lui de l'air la sirène de la
voiture de police est une délivrance
la civière est une délivrance ces hommes
en uniforme calme qui ont l'habitude
sont réconfortants plus personne n'est
responsable
le petit drame va suivre son cours
ailleurs quelque part dans un hôpital la
collectivité rassurer le vieillard
cahoter dans l'ambulance a les yeux clos
l'infirmier pencher sur lui cherche des
papiers une identité quelqu'un à
prévenir mais rien rien qu'une lettre
froissé dans une poche vide
une lettre qui a dû être lu et relu cent
fois vieille de plusieurs semaines une
fois sur un lit d'hôpital
une fois le diagnostic établi que faire
cet homme va mourir son coeur refuse de
lutter il va s'arrêter d'une heure à
l'autre comme un vieux rêve est usé il
faudrait prévenir quelqu'un l'infirmier
regard de la lettre c'est celle d'un
soldat en garnison à l'autre bout de
l'europe
le matricule 56000 vannes 3 il y a un
nom gallen avec un j les quelques lignes
ne donne guère de renseignement le
soldat est le fils de cet homme mais ne
parle que de détail sans importance sur
la vie de la caserne
il n'y a qu'une phrase un peu plus
intime attends moi ne sois pas triste
je n'en ai plus pour très longtemps
alors l'infirmier se décident tout d'un
coup un nom un matricule une caserne
d'europe ça ne doit pas être difficile à
trouver bon sens et le téléphone ça
existe des avions aussi alors avec un
peu de chance il se penche sur le
vieillard toujours immobile dans ses
draps blancs
monsieur c'est votre fils vous voulez le
voir
l'homme n'a pas parlé depuis qu'on l'a
ramassée sur le trottoir il ouvre à
peine les yeux il voit la lettre il
dessert les lèvres avec peine une larme
glisse au coin de cet abri d il n'a pas
la force de l'effacer et l'infirmier en
temps comme un souffle mon fils alors
ils foncent à l'administration de
l'hôpital et il se bat avec le téléphone
il n'est que cinq heures de l'après midi
à marseille
en moins d'une heure c'est un exploit
l'infirmier a réussi à joindre le bureau
militaire ou quelqu'un comprend de quoi
il s'agit on note le matricule on note
gallen j ai la caserne on note que le
père de ce matricule est en train de
mourir et réclame son fils et le message
rebondi il met deux heures à rebondir
jusqu'à la caserne lointaine où un
adjudant de services va trouver un
colonel et lui expose la situation et le
colonel signe une permission il est huit
heures du soir avec l'aide de la croix
rouge on trouve une place dans un avion
sanitaire jusqu'à genève
il est 10 heures du soir à genève le
soldat attrape un vol sur marseille
11h20 il est dans le taxi 11h40
il est à l'hôpital et le voilà enfin
dans le couloir blanc qui mène à la
chambre blanche où le vieillard l'attend
l'infirmier lui serre la main et s'en va
laissant seul le père et le fils le père
et sous une tente à oxygène son regard
flou s'accroche à la silhouette en
uniforme debout devant son lit l'une de
ses mains ce temps péniblement le fils à
une seconde d'hésitation
et puis ils s'approchent sa grande main
saisi les doigts fragile il s'assoit et
ne bouge plus
les heures passent lentement
le vieillard a les traits reposés des
tordus deux ou trois fois il a tenté de
parler mais sa voix ne résonne plus il a
seulement murmurait le prénom de son
fils jean le reste il le dit avec sa
main que la main du soldat ne lâche pas
et le soldat veille le fils veille ils
calment les terreurs soudaine de son
vieux père il essuie le front en sueur
il dit des choses rassurantes par
moments une infirmière vient regarde les
instruments vérifie le goutte à goutte
et puis se retire sur la pointe des
pieds avec un sourire peiné le vieil
homme ne lutte plus il n'a plus mal
nulle part on a soulagé sa fin on l'aide
à respirer on l'aide à mourir dans le
calme
c'est tout ce qu'on peut faire mais
c'est déjà bien qu'il est son fils près
de lui même s'il ne peut plus le
distinguer il sent la présence de ce
corps solide vivant il est 5 heures du
matin et les deux mains la vieille la
jeune ne se sont pas quittés il est 5
heures du matin l'europe du 20 octobre
1962 se lève à marseille
le souffle du vieillard s'est arrêté sa
main a relâché sa pression
l'infirmière entre elles tournent à
boutons des branches un appareil c'est
fini
doucement le soldat dégage sa main et il
regarde une dernière fois le mort en
face l'infirmière dit c'est fini
monsieur votre père est mort
tranquillement revenez plus tard pour
les formalités
il faut vous reposer alors le solde à la
regarde
c'est un grand garçon bien calme je veux
cours aux yeux tranquille
il a 22 ans et il dit ce n'était pas mon
père mademoiselle je n'avais jamais vu
de ma vie
il faut prévenir sa famille
mais alors pourquoi n'avez vous rien dit
qui êtes vous il n'avait rien dit parce
qu'on entend dans cette chambre il
s'était rendu compte en même temps que
cet homme n'était pas son père mais
qu'il avait besoin d'un fils pour mourir
seulement d'un fils il pouvait être ce
fils alors il était resté haut pour le
reste
l'erreur était simple et bête on avait
transmis le message au matricule 46000
23 soldats valent à jacques c'est à dire
lui une erreur compréhensible car le
véritable fils portait un numéro
matricule voisins et s'appelait gallen
gens avec un g alors jacques avait été
gens pour la nuit
une longue nuit silencieuse entre père
et fils une nuit hors du temps librement
consenti universel et symbolique sous
l'oeil ébahi du personnel de l'hôpital
le soldat jacques vallin est reparti
comme il était venu
il avait donné la tendresse les
formalités ne le concernait pas
[Musique]